j ai nous avons agi de toutes nos forces
nous avons agi contre le terrorisme et
son terreau fertile la radicalisation la
loi sécurité intérieure et lutte contre
le terrorisme qui a été votée dès l'été
2010 est a permis les visites
domiciliaires a permis de fermer les
lieux de culte radicaliser tout en
sortant rappelons le de l'état d'urgence
nous avons réorganisé nos services de
renseignement et judicaire national
antiterroriste nous avons recruté 1900
agents et doubler leur budget par
rapport à 2015 nous avons lancé le suivi
des individus radicalisés sortant de
prison qui n'avait que trop attendu nous
avons mis en place une tolérance face à
la moindre en taille à notre pacte
républicain depuis février 2018 près de
25000 contrôles ont eu lieu dans des
établissements où l'on soupçonnait des
atteintes aux principes républicains
grâce à ces contrôles 662 établissements
ont pu être fermé et 45 millions d'euros
ont pu être redressée la loi confortant
le respect des principes de la
république promulguée cet été et la
dernière étape en date de notre lutte
inflexible contre le séparatisme
elle offre un meilleur contrôle des
services publics des associations et
assure que chaque enfant reçoive une
éducation républicaine nous avons
réinvesti massivement dans nos forces de
l'ordre et pour leurs conditions de
travail sur le quinquennat dix mille
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
auront été recrutés nous avons renouvelé
les deux tiers de leur parc automobile
et fin 2021 700 casernes et
commissariats auront été rénovée depuis
2010 est le budget du ministère de
l'intérieur a augmenté de 2,5 milliards
d'euros c'est une augmentation
considérable est pleinement justifiée et
le président de la république a annoncé
hier que le ministère de l'intérieur
connaîtrait l'année prochaine une
augmentation de 1,5 milliard d'euros de
son budget ses 500 millions d'euros de
plus que ce qui avait été prévu les
moyens sont une chose mais nous avons
mené aussi une lutte inflexible contre
les délinquants contre les violences et
notamment les violences conjugales
contre les stupéfiants depuis le début
du quinquennat trente six attentats ont
été déjoués les cambriolages ont baissé
d'un quart on a compté 20 % de véhicules
volés en moins ces vingt-huit mille
victimes en moins nous avons avancé
aussi à pas de géants contre les trafics
grâce à notre stratégie de pilonnages
rien que ce semestre près de 8000 trafic
ont été démantelés 6000 trafiquants
interpellés les saisies de cannabis ont
augmenté de près de 40% et celle de
cocaïne ont quasiment doublé quant aux
amendes forfaitaires pour les
consommateurs qui permettent une
sanction immédiate cent mille ont été
dressés en une année mais évidemment
beaucoup reste à accomplir beaucoup
reste encore à construire et à
consolider et le président de la
république l'a redit ce matin nous
refusons le déni et nous récusons
l'incantation nous agissons trop souvent
aujourd'hui quelques-uns remettent en
cause l'autorité de nos forces de
l'ordre est en partie lié le poison de
la division entre elles et les français
cela ne marchera pas policiers et
gendarmes ne seront jamais considérés
comme une bande rivale ils sont l'ordre
républicain et il mérite le respect et
les pleins moyens de leur action c'est
pour cette raison que le président de la
république avait lancé en février
dernier le bouvau de la sécurité il
s'agissait de regarder en face les défis
de nos forces de l'ordre et d'y répondre
avec méthode et ambition pas simplement
par plus de moyens plus d'effectifs plus
d'équipements mais aussi par des
transformations plus radicale depuis
plusieurs mois des dizaines de réunions
des changes se sont tenus et ont permis
à des policiers à des gendarmes à des
magistrats des experts à des citoyens de
préparer ensemble la sécurité
d'aujourd'hui et de demain le président
de la république a fait hier et à des
conclusions de ce beauvau nous faisons
encore montée d'un cran la sécurité des
français et nous prenons date avec les
forces de l'ordre nous allons sur 10 ans
doubler les effectifs de policiers et de
gendarmes dans nos rues pour cela nous
allons nous attaquer à la paperasserie à
toutes les piles de dossiers qui sont
autant d'entravés entre les policiers et
les délinquants une remise à plat du
code de procédure pénale sera ainsi
lancée et elle permettra aux forces de
l'ordre de se concentrer pleinement sur
leur coeur de métier nous allons aussi
en partenariat avec les organisations
syndicales entamé une évolution des
cycles horaire nous voulons construire
la police et la gendarmerie de 2030
adaptée aux défis de sécurité de demain
c'est pourquoi une loi de programmation
de la sécurité intérieure sera présenté
en conseil des ministres début 2022 elle
permettra de concrétiser des engagements
fermes et d'inscrire la remontée en
puissance de nos forces de l'ordre dans
la durée nous allons améliorer la prise
en charge et l'accueil des victimes et
permettre dès 2023 la généralisation de
la plainte en ligne nous allons
continuer à améliorer les conditions
d'engagement des forces de l'ordre un
nouvel uniforme sera mis en production
et distribué à partir du premier
trimestre 2011 22 le déploiement de 30
mille caméras piétons s'achèvera dans
les délais prévus et nous irons plus
loin encore avec des caméras
individuelles et des caméras embarquées
dans les véhicules enfin la police le
sait le contrôle et la garantie du
respect de son action est une instance
parlementaire de contrôle de l'action
des forces de l'ordre sera créé et
évidemment c'est ce que le président de
la république a proposé aux présidents
des deux assemblées ce conseil des
ministres a également été l'occasion
vous l'imaginez d'un nouveau point sur
la situation sanitaire car l'épidémie
malheureusement n'est pas encore
derrière nous l'embellie sanitaires se
confirme jour après jour dans l'hexagone
c'est une bonne nouvelle le nombre de
cas quotidiens et proche des dix mille
en moyenne en diminution de 25% par
rapport à la semaine dernière la
pression dans les hôpitaux est en
réanimation baisse elle aussi de 7%
environ sur la semaine passée nous
sommes repassés cette semaine sous la
barre des 10000 patients hospitalisés le
taux d'incidence approche des 100 au
niveau national un niveau qu'il n'avait
pas atteint depuis le mois de juillet et
près de 20 départements voient leur
incidence repasser en dessous des 50
pour cent mille habitants
désormais le taux d'incidence des
pailles dépasse le seuil d alerte
maximale de 200 dans une seule région
métropolitaine dans la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur le nombre de
cas diminue néanmoins de façon continue
comme dans le reste de l'hexagone depuis
plus d'un mois et nous sommes à des
niveaux de contamination qui sont
presque trois fois plus bas qu'au début
du mois d'août néanmoins outre mer la
situation reste très préoccupante
les taux d'incidence il reste très élevé
à 2 163 en guadeloupe à 290 en
martinique et à 409 en guyane dans les
antilles l'épidémie qui a fait des
ravages du fait de la sous vaccination
nation est désormais en net reflux la
guadeloupe a désormais deux fois moins
de patients en réanimation que sommet de
la vague et la tension hospitalière en
martinique diminue depuis plusieurs
jours c'est la preuve que nos mesures de
freinage difficile mais nécessaire que
la mobilisation exceptionnelle de
soignants en renfort qui ont été prises
au coeur de l'été sont en train de
porter leurs fruits dans le cas de la
guyane nous restons particulièrement en
alerte la tension hospitalière
aujourd'hui à 90 % ne diminue pas et les
mesures de freinage resteront en place
autant que nécessaire pour sortir de
cette quatrième vague nous continuons
aussi à suivre la situation extrêmement
tendue de la polynésie française
l'archipel payent un lourd tribut avec
encore 24 décès ces dernières heures la
situation
tend à commencer à s'améliorer je prends
beaucoup de pincettes car elle demeure
extrêmement tendue avec des services de
réanimation qui sont à la quasi
saturation des renforts humains et
matériels vous le savez ont été envoyés
pour soutenir les équipes sur place sur
tout le territoire à la veille de
l'automne nous devons rester extrêmement
vigilant 40% des capacités de nos
réanimation restent occupés par des
patients qu'aux vide c'est beaucoup
comme nous le rappelait l'institut
pasteur la semaine dernière des mesures
de contrôle sont encore plus que
nécessaire pour prévenir un rebond
hivernale de l'épidémie c'est notamment
le sens de l'obligation vaccinale pour
les personnels soignants qui entre en
vigueur aujourd'hui cette mesure je veux
le rappeler a été annoncée par le
président de la république le 12 juillet
dernier et elle vise à une chose à
protéger notre hôpital à protéger nos
soignants à protéger les patients
fragiles
à ce jour l'immense majorité des
soignants a fait le choix de la
responsabilité et de la protection
collective depuis l'allocution du
président de la république nous avons
laissé deux mois au plus hésitants
d'entre eux pour se faire vacciner et
l'incitation à porter ses fruits puisque
nous sommes passés de 64% de soignants
vacciner début juillet à plus de neuf
sur dix aujourd'hui et je veux au nom du
président de la république remercier les
millions de soignants qui ont
massivement répondu à l'exigence de se
faire vacciner ils ont été exemplaires
depuis le début de cette crise dans leur
mobilisation pour soigner les français
ils sont exemple aujourd'hui par leur
esprit de responsabilité et leur volonté
de protéger les autres en se faisant
vacciner la règle va s'appliquer dès
aujourd'hui les soignants qui n'ont reçu
aucune dose de vaccin pourront être
suspendus par leur direction ceux qui
n'ont reçu qu'une dose bénéficieront
d'une période de tolérance jusqu'au 15
octobre le temps de recevoir leur
deuxième dose nous ne stigmatisons
personnes nous responsabilisons tout le
monde cette mesure est nécessaire elle
est connue depuis deux mois et surtout
elle est urgente personne n'est plus
exposée cas personnel soignant il n'y a
pas de contamination plus risquée que
celle d'un personnel soignant qui
accueille des personnes fragiles des
malades fragiles et concernant le danger
du virus pour eux et leurs patients
fragiles il n'y a pas mieux informé que
le personnel soignant vis-à-vis des
risques nous surveillerons bien sûr au
cas par cas la bonne application de ces
mesures dans les services hospitaliers
avec fermeté et discernement enfin le
président de la république a tenu à
revenir sur le sujet fondamental de la
biodiversité pendant quelques jours
marseille a été la capitale mondiale de
la biodiversité avec le congrès mondial
de la nature dont la ministre de la
transition écologique et la secrétaire
d'état chargé de la biodiversité nous
ont présenté ce matin les principales
conclusions prenons exemple sur
l'ambition de la politique française en
matière d'aires protégées l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature a appelé tous les états à
protéger 30% de leurs territoires
terrestres et maritimes la france a elle
même pris des engagements notamment pour
atteindre la protection forte de 5 % des
eaux en méditerranée pour la création de
nouvelles réserves de nouveaux parcs
nationaux pour la lutte contre la
déforestation importés ou plus
globalement pour intégrer la
préservation des écosystèmes dans
l'ensemble de ses politiques publiques
dans les mois à venir nous allons
approfondir cette ambition la présidence
française de l'union européenne qui
démarre vous le savez début 2022 portera
une initiative ambitieuse en matière de
réduction des pesticides les moyens liés
à la biodiversité seront renforcés en
2022 avec un soutien accru aux
opérateurs et la création de 20 postes
supplémentaires dans les parcs nationaux
enfin nous accueillerons courant demi 2
un nouveau sommet consacré cette fois ci
à la préservation des océans
mesdames et messieurs ce conseil des
ministres a également été l'occasion
d'examiner un certain nombre de textes
sur lesquels je vais revenir très
brièvement mais qui ont pour fil rouge
de poursuivre un train de l'attraction
de simplification drastique de nos
procédures et de nos règles le premier
ministre a présenté un projet de loi
ratifiant une ordonnance relative au
financement de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
elle facilite le recouvrement des
contributions employeur avec la mise en
place d'un collecteur unique l'urssaf
pour la plus grande partie d'entre elles
mais aussi l'utilisation d'une
déclaration sociale nominative et la
mensualisation de la taxe
d'apprentissage le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
bruno le maire a quant à lui présenté
plusieurs textes qui sont issus je veux
le dire notamment d'un travail
remarquable auquel a pris part rené
ricol que je veux celle du lait ici
premièrement une ordonnance portant
création du registre national des
entreprises au 1er janvier 2023 cette
mesure prévue par la loi pacte créera un
outil de référence en matière
d'information économique et juridique
sur chacune des structures
deuxièmement une ordonnance généralisant
la facturation électronique entre
assujettis à la tva c'est là aussi une
simplification majeure de la vie des
entreprises qui pourrait apporter
jusqu'à 4,5 milliards d'euros mais aussi
améliorer la détection de la fraude
encore massive à la tva dans notre pays
enfin une ordonnance présentée avec le
ministre d outre-mer portant réforme du
code monétaire et financier dans ces
territoires elle a pour objet
d'améliorer la lisibilité du droit
bancaire et financier en outre-mer de
mettre à jour certaines dispositions et
d'en introduire de nouvelles qu'il n'y
était pas encore appliqué deux
ordonnances ont aussi été présenté par
le garde des sceaux la première réforme
le droit des sûretés qui constitue un
enjeu économique primordial en matière
d'octroi des crédits de financement de
l'économie ce texte auront le droit des
sûretés plus simple plus lisible et plus
efficace ce petit abou raad et ce qui
aboutira des dispositifs plus sécurisant
pour l'ensemble des parties prenantes
enfin la dernière ordonnance du garde
des sceaux concernait la réforme des
procédures collectives là aussi en
application de la loi acte et d'une
directive européenne relative aux cadres
de restructuration préventive ces
procédures visent rappelons le a assuré
le maintien de l'activité et des emplois
ainsi nous renforçons les dispositifs de
détection et de prévention des
difficultés afin de favoriser le recours
aux conciliation le droit à une seconde
chance des entrepreneurs individuels
sera lui aussi renforcé enfin le
privilège de sauvegarde et de
redressement judiciaire disposition qui
avait été prise vous le savez pendant la
crise sanitaire pour faciliter le
financement des entreprises en
difficulté sera pérennisée l'ensemble de
ces textes je le disais atteste de la
poursuite d'un agenda de simplification
ambitieux par le gouvernement voilà ce
que je pouvais vous dire mesdames
messieurs du conseil des ministres de ce
jour et je me tiens à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions
pourquoi
revenir
d'abord je veux rappeler vous l'avez
indiqué que plus de 9 soignant sur dix
se sont fait vacciner que beaucoup de
chemin a été parcouru au niveau national
depuis l'allocution du président de la
république je le rappelais à l'instant
64% au début du mois de juillet près de
90% aujourd'hui et nous nous attendons
en réalité est ce que ce soit un peu
plus parce que certains soignants
n'avait pas déclaré à leurs employeurs
qu'ils avaient été vaccinés et c'est
aujourd'hui finalement au moment de
vérité entre guillemets ou un certain
nombre d'entre eux feront connaître leur
statut vaccinal à leur employeur je
disais que nous allons nous allions
appliquer cette règle partout en faisant
preuve au cas par cas de fermeté et de
discernement j'évoquais tout à l'heure
la situation hospitalière encore très
tendus notamment aux antilles qui fait
suite à une vague de contamination très
forte c'était suite malheureusement être
sous vaccination de la population
localement même si là aussi des progrès
ont été effectués et quand je parlais de
discernement tout à l'heure c'est
qu'évidemment à un moment où notre
hôpital est pleinement mobilisé ou des
soignants sont arrivés en renfort ou les
soignants se bat face à une saturation
des hôpitaux dans ces territoires même
si la pression a évidemment commencé à
diminuer heureusement évidemment que
nous faisons preuve de discernement mais
dès lors que la vague sera à passer et
que nous serons de l'autre côté de la
vague évidemment cette règle
s'appliquera avec la même fermeté dans
ces hôpitaux dans ces territoires que
dans le reste de notre pays
- jean-marie chanterait pour tf1 lci une
question concernant l'accélération de
l'inflation est ce que vous confirmez
que le smic ce sera bien augmentée
oui je vous
le confirme d'abord ce que je veux
rappeler c'est que depuis le début de ce
quinquennat nous avons une politique
visant à favoriser le pouvoir d'achat de
ceux qui travaillent et notamment de
ceux qui travaillent avec les plus
faibles rémunérations ceux qui sont au
smic nous avons augmenté la prime
d'activité pour des millions de français
nous avons défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires nous avons baissé les
cotisations salariales et je ne parle
ici que des mesures qui concerne le
travail puisqu'il ya aussi des mesures
en matière d'impôt nous avons à baisser
l'impôt sur le revenu 5 milliards
d'euros pour 17 millions de ménages nous
avons supprimé la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des français c'est 360 euros de
gains en moyenne toute cette action et
vise à augmenter pouvoir d'achat de ceux
qui travaillent et encore une fois
notamment de ceux qui travaillent avec
les plus faibles salaires parce qu'il
faut toujours que travailler soit plus
intéressant que ne pas travailler
il ya eu une inflation très forte cet
été qui a été notamment tirée par une
augmentation des prix des matières
premières et des prix des tarifs de
l'énergie c'est aussi la conséquence
d'une reprise économique très forte que
nous constatons partout dans le monde et
donc d'une demande très forte notamment
en termes de matières premières et
d'énergie il ya donc vous le savez dans
le cas d'une augmentation de l'inflation
très forte des règles qui s'appliquent
c'est la loi et nous avons toujours
appliquer ces règles et donc une
revalorisation au dôme automatique dans
ce cas pour compenser cette augmentation
des prix pour compenser cette inflation
encore une fois dans une logique de
préservation du pouvoir d'achat de ceux
qui travaillent et donc cette règle a
vocation à s'appliquer la ministre du
travail lisa bête bornes va réunir en
fin de journée le groupe d'experts sur
le smic elle aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer à l'issue de cette réunion
pour communiquer les détails de cette
revalorisation
une question aussi sur la flambée des
prix des matières premières est ce que
vous envisagez
d'étendre à plus le chèque énergie a
plus de français qui en bénéficient
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup je le disais
il ya un instant l'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie évidemment un impact pour
beaucoup de français ce qu'indiquait
bruno le maire il ya quelques jours
c'est que nous anticipions que à la
suite de cette hausse très importante
encore une fois qui est liée à la
reprise économique il y à une
stabilisation mais sans attendre
évidemment que nous nous avons agi sur
ce sujet là des difficultés de pouvoir
d'achat lié à la facture énergétique
depuis le début du quinquennat nous
faisons encore avec le plan de relance
de manière structurelle le meilleur
moyen d'avoir une facture d'énergie qui
baisse c'est de pouvoir isoler son
logement et je veux rappeler le
dispositif ma prime rénove qui permet à
tous les français de bénéficier d'une
prime jusqu'à 20000 euros quand il fait
des travaux pour isoler son logement
c'est un dispositif qui est de plus en
plus connu il ya de plus en plus de
recours on parle ici du long terme et
évidemment la question du court terme la
fin du mois pour des français qui ont du
mal à joindre les deux bouts pour ceux
qui travaillent à les mesures que
j'évoquais pour augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat de celles et ceux qui
travaillent encore une fois avec les
revalorisations automatiques liées à
l'inflation mais aussi avec des mesures
de soutien au pouvoir d'achat les
mesures que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
pour une personne au smic c'est
l'équivalent d'un treizième mois et d'un
demi 14e mois à la fin de l'année grâce
aux mesures que nous avons prises depuis
le début du quinquennat et puis à des
français qui se sont en précarité des
français à modeste et là nous avons un
outil que nous avons élargi qui est le
chèque énergie vous savez qu'il ya une
aide qui est versé à ces foyers à
plusieurs millions de foyers qui ont des
difficultés à payer leurs factures
d'énergie c'est une aide c'est en
fonction des revenus j'ai en tête un
montant qui va d'une cinquantaine
d'euros à 200 euros environ évidemment
la situation actuelle augmentation des
prix nous conduit à travailler sur ce
dispositif et à regarder dans quelle
mesure il est nécessaire de l'élargir
pour qu'il puisse concerner plus de
français plus de ménages en difficulté
il y avait beaucoup de travaux qui ont
été menées ces derniers jours par le
gouvernement et le premier ministre aura
l'occasion de faire des annonces sur ce
sujet dans les jours qui viennent
bonjour michel rose de reuters je
voulais revenir sur la vaccination on a
atteint un très haut niveau en france
à la fin de cet été et pourtant il ya
toujours une un point faible en france
c'est la vaccination des plus de 80 ans
on est à seulement 15% il reste encore
15 % et + 80 ans qui ne sont pas
vaccinés alors que dans d'autres pays
européens on a 100 % des plus de 80 ans
qui sont vaccinées on nous a parlé de
d'aller vers de
mesures pour essayer de vacciner ces
personnes là mais on n'a pas
l'impression qu'on a l'impression que ça
stagne en tout cas c'est ces derniers
mois et ce qu'il ya d'autres mesures qui
sont prévus pour vacciner les plus
vulnérables
vous l'avez dit on à un très haut niveau
de vaccination en france qui nous
placent en tête des pays comparables
dans le peloton de tête si on veut être
exact des pays comparables revient de
loin sur ce sujet là et grâce à
l'intervention du président de la
république le 12 juillet il ya eu un
rebond exceptionnel de la vaccination
cet été dans les six semaines qui ont
suivi l'intervention du président de la
république ses 12 millions de français
qui sont allés se faire vacciner
par définition vous le savez c'est du
bon sens nos concitoyens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés aujourd'hui sont probablement
les plus difficiles à atteindre et des
plus difficiles a amené à se faire
vacciner soit parce parce que leur
hésitation est très forte et qu'il ne
souhaite pas se faire vacciner dans ce
cas là le travail de pédagogie des
changes est évidemment beaucoup plus
long soit parce que s'agissant notamment
des plus âgés ils sont très isolés
parfois peu ou pas l'accompagner et donc
fait très difficile de leur permettre de
rejoindre un centre de vaccination est
bien souvent il faut se rendre au
domicile mais encore faut-il les
identifier et c'est pour ça que ce que
nous continuons à amplifier c'est notre
action d'aller vers donc continuer à
amplifier cette action d'aller vers
c'est pas simple c'est évidemment
difficile moi je veux saluer le travail
remarquable qui est fait par évidemment
les services de l'état met en lien avec
les professionnels de santé localement
en lien avec les associations en lien
avec les collectivités locales qui ont
notamment le fichier le fameux fichier
canicule via les centres communaux
d'action sociale pour aller toucher les
personnes les plus âgées
je vais aussi revenir sur le rôle qu'ont
et que peuvent avoir que devrait avoir
je pense encore davantage les médecins
traitants puisque ils ont la possibilité
vous le savez nous leur avons donné la
possibilité avec autorisation de la cnil
de pouvoir accéder aux fichiers de leurs
patients qui sont vaccinées donc
d'identifier leurs patients qui ne sont
pas vaccinés un médecin peut aujourd'hui
avoir la liste de ces patients qui sont
vaccinés identifiés ces patients qui ne
sont pas vaccinés et donc voir notamment
parmi ses patients les plus âgés et
fragiles ceux qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés à ce moment là leur passer un
coup de fil plus un millier le font
beaucoup le font mais on peut évidemment
faire davantage et c'est cette action
que nous allons poursuivre parce que
nous savons que les plus âgés sont les
plus à risque de faire une forme grave
c'est un risque pour eux mais c'est
évidemment aussi un risque pour notre
hôpital
bonjour monsieur le ministre mais ce
maxi pour canal+ ses news eric zemmour
est crédité entre 8 et 10% dans les
sondages est très probable possiblement
en tout cas candidat à la présidentielle
est ce que ça vous arrange est ce que ça
vous inquiète
vous savez moi je ça c'est une règle que
nous suffixe ici je fais pas de je
m'exprime pas sur la politique entre
guillemets politicienne les élections
etc je suis ici dans mon cadre très
institutionnel de par parole du
gouvernement à la suite du conseil des
ministres où je vous rend compte de
l'action du gouvernement mais je me
rends régulièrement sur des plateaux de
télévision je réponds à la presse en
tant que la responsable politique je
peux m'exprimer sur ces sujets là et je
suis sûr que j'aurai l'occasion de le
faire à nouveau puisque ça a déjà été le
cas dans les jours qui viennent
bonjour j -marie le tour de france info
je reviens sur ce que vous nous disiez
sur l'augmentation notamment du prix du
gaz
nous avons évoqué un certain nombre de
dispositifs pour les familles les plus
précaires les classes moyennes semble
assez souvent oubliée dans ce dans ce
genre de débat qu'est ce que vous leur
dites aujourd'hui
précisément vous avez raison les classes
moyennes aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
français qui travaillent avec des plus
faibles revenus que les autres qui
subissent l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie et dont le revenu ne permet
pas suffisamment d'assumer ces dépenses
sont très impactées est ce que je vous
disais à l'instant c'est que c'est aussi
le sens des mesures que nous prenons
depuis 2010 est pour que leur travail
paye plus quand on revalorise la prime
d'activité pour toutes ses classes
moyennes quand on défiscalise les heures
supplémentaires quand on prend toutes
nos mesures sur l'impôt sur le revenu je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure pour les
premières tranches sur la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation pour 80% des
français précisément on prend des
mesures qui visent à augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des classes moyennes
maintenant je disais à l'instant qu'il
ya une augmentation très forte soudaine
et pris 2 énergie cet été qui est liée à
la reprise économique qui concerne il
faut le dire l'intégralité du monde que
nous avons travaillé nous travaillons à
des mesures supplémentaires que le
premier ministre aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer dans les jours à venir sur
sur le discernement que vous évoquez
quant à l'obligation vaccinale outre-mer
je vous avoue que ce n'est pas très bien
compris votre réponse parce qu'en fait
il sent qu'il ya un paradoxe dans la
mesure où précisément le que vide étant
une maladie qui se transmet aussi à
l'hôpital on a le sentiment que
outre-mer et dans des dans les
départements où le virus circule encore
beaucoup c'est une l'endroit même où il
faudrait que cette obligation soit
vacciné donc est ce que c'est une forme
d'aveu d'impuissance face à la fois la
question du recrutement de personnels
hospitaliers
outre-mer ou face à la situation de
l'hôpital public dans ces territoires à
l'hôpital public dans ces territoires il
est soutenu je pourrais vous citer les
projets d'investissements colossaux qui
sont portées par l'état depuis plusieurs
années pour construire ou reconstruire
des établissements hospitaliers
évidemment que des mesures pour
favoriser le recrutement de personnel
soignant localement je veux rappeler
aussi la mobilisation exceptionnelle des
soignants de la réserve sanitaire
notamment qui ont été mobilisés depuis
le coeur de l'été sur place je crois
qu'on est à 2000 soignants qui auront
été mobilisés en tout maintenant je vais
vous dire les choses et le plus
clairement et plus concrètement possible
vous avez des hôpitaux qui sont encore
très tendu qui sont pour certains à la
quasi saturation si vous avez un
personnel soignant qui intervient dans
cet hôpital pour soigner des patients
dans un contexte de tension extrême
qu'il aujourd'hui n'est pas vaccinée est
ce que vous le suspens des comme vous le
faites dans un hôpital où la tension n'a
rien à voir et où la tension n'est pas
aussi forte tout faire preuve de
discernement de manière temporaire tant
qu'on est encore sur le quasi sommet de
la vague mais ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est que la situation
commence à s'améliorer qu'elle
s'améliore même nettement dans certains
territoires et que dès que ce sera
possible nous appliquerons la règle de
la même manière partout sur le
territoire encore une fois moi je je je
comprends ces questions ce que je pense
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on consacre
autant de temps à part et des endroits
où épisodiquement il peut y avoir oui
pour des raisons de discernement de
pragmatisme une règle qui appliquée avec
souplesse dans un premier temps que
parler de la totalité du reste de notre
territoire où la règle est appliquée
avec fermeté qu'on passe autant de temps
à parler comme le font beaucoup de
médias des 8 9 10% de soignants qui ne
se sont pas fait vacciner on passe
autant de temps à parler des 90 91 92 %
de soignants qui ont eu la
responsabilité de se faire vacciner
je reviens sur les annonces en matière
de politique de sécurité
vous nous dites doublement à 10 ans il
ya d une élection présidentielle dans
sept mois est ce que ça veut dire
que vous considérez la victoire comme
acquise est ce que ça veut dire que ça
n'est ce ne sont pas des engagements
mais ça n'est qu'une vision ou est ce
que vous prévoyez des mécanismes qui
font que le travail engagé maintenant ne
sera pas perdu dans cette main en cas
d'alternance
il ya eu un premier temps dans ce
quinquennat sur matière de sécurité qui
visait je le disais à l'instant à mettre
fin à l'hémorragie notamment en termes
d'effectifs dans des cas certains
quinquennat précédent c'est plus de
10000 postes de policiers de gendarmes
qui ont été supprimés on ne recrée 10000
sur ce quinquennat mettre fin à
l'hémorragie aussi en augmentant les
budgets je parlais à l'instant 2
milliards 500 millions d'euros de plus
depuis début juin qaîda ont rajouté un
milliard et demi l'an prochain on
renouvelle on aura renouvelé les deux
tiers du parc automobile rénovée 700
commissariats et casernes à la fin de
cette année 2021 augmente la
rémunération nos policiers aussi avec
une augmentation de l'indemnité 200
euros nets par mois pour nos forces de
l'ordre il ya cette action qui était une
action d'urgence d'investissement et
puis le bobo de la sécurité il a permis
d'aller au plus profond des difficultés
de d'imaginer pendant plusieurs mois de
travail avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes des solutions plus pérennes
plus durable en s'inscrivant sur le
temps long parce que la sécurité c'est
aussi une affaire de tendre et si on
veut changer profondément la manière
dont nos policiers et nos gendarmes sont
formés la manière dont ils exercent au
quotidien la manière dont les français
sont protégés en ayant davantage de
présence sur terrain il faut prendre
date avec nos forces de l'ordre il faut
s'inscrire dans du temps long
vous savez on a 10 de plus début qu'on
n'agirait jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure
qu'est ce que ce serait si sous prétexte
qu à une élection présidentielle dans
huit ou dix mois on se mettait tout d'un
coup à dire bah écoutez il ya une
élection présidentielle dans huit mois
je peux citer 8 ou 10 mois on va arrêter
d'agir banon évidemment jusqu'au dernier
moment on continuera âge et donc oui il
y aura une loi de programmation qui sera
présentée adopté en conseil des
ministres des mines début 2022 ensuite
vous l'avais dit il ya évidemment des
échéances électorales et j'imagine que
quel que soit le gouvernement qui aura
été nommé après cette élection
présidentielle en tout cas je l'espère
ils auront à coeur de s'engager sur ce
sujet de la sécurité ils disposeront
pour cela d'un projet de loi qui aura
été adopté en conseil des ministres
transmis au parlement qui permettra
d'aller plus loin pour la sécurité des
français
bonjour à yanis boom de bloomberg juste
une précision sur les prix de l'énergie
vous disais que vous attendiez à ce
qu'enfin que le gouvernement s'attend à
une stabilisation des prix de l'énergie
dans les prochains mois c'est ça je
faisais référence à des propos de bruno
le maire qu'il a tenus dans la presse je
serai chez qui c'était mais c'était chez
certains de vos confrères évidemment en
tout cas on l'espère mais je vous
renvoie aux propos de mon collègue
bonjour laurence benhammo afp
monsieur castex a donné son feu vert à
de nouvelles salles de shoot à paris et
au passage on comprend qu'il a arbitré
pour prolonger ces expérimentations de
salles de shoot dans les grandes villes
est ce que vous estimez que
effectivement c'est la bonne solution
qu'il faut les multiplier dans les
grandes villes et correspondait vous aux
riverains qui s'inquiètent par exemple
comme dans ce quartier où il ya une
école près de près de laquelle se
trouvera une de ses salles et deuxième
question il ya beaucoup de mesures qui
sont annoncées en ce moment et qui sont
financés par le plan de relance le plan
de relance post que vides que répondez
vous à ceux qui disent que finalement ça
tombe très bien pour une campagne de
finances et consorts le carnet de
chèques avec cette manne
à laquelle on ne s'attendait pas merci
sur le premier point c'est une solution
une solution importante qui est permise
par la loi vous le savez c'est une loi
qui a été adoptée en 2016 à l'initiative
de marisol touraine c'est un dispositif
qui permet d'accompagner des
consommateurs de drogue vers le sevrage
ça s'appelle les salles de consommation
à moindre risque s'agissant de la
situation
très difficile pour les toxicomanes pour
les riverains que nous constatons dans
le nord-est parisien nous avons une
volonté qui est clair qui est répété
c'est de permettre aux riverains de
retrouver le calme et la sécurité dans
leur quartier et offrir une solution de
sevrage durable aux consommateurs qui
sont présents et nous voulons trouver
des solutions et nous avons pris notre
part pour trouver des solutions je veux
rappeler que conformément à notre
engagement une unité de police est
présente durablement sur le terrain
parce qu'évidemment la première des
priorités c'est de mettre fin au trafic
et d'interpeller les trafiquants je veux
rappeler que 400 places de repos ont été
installés et que nous continuons
évidemment à en chercher que les
services de l'état sont mobilisés et
qu'évidemment nous souhaitons continuer
à avancer avec les autres acteurs et
notamment la mairie de paris et la
mairie de paris a fait part lundi de son
souhait d'installer des sites des salles
de consommation à moindre risque pour
accueillir les toxicomanes et je
rappelle que ce dispositif a pour
vocation de les accompagner vers le
sevrage de les mettre dans un processus
qui vise à les conduire vers le sevrage
elle a proposé plusieurs lieux je crois
qu'il ya quatre lieux qui ont été
proposées et nous lui avons répondu que
nous étions évidemment prêts à continuer
à avancer pour trouver un lieu
localement pour installer ce dispositif
c'est évidemment la première
responsabilité de la mairie de paris qui
propose évidemment nous ensuite on
regarde on instruit et puis on autorise
le cas échéant ce que nous lui avions ce
que nous lui avons répondu et le premier
ministre la faire par courrier c'est
qu'il nous semble juste totalement
impossible d'installer une de ses salles
à proximité immédiate d'une école comme
ça a été proposée par la mairie de paris
ça c'est juste pas possible pas
installer ce dispositif qui vise à
accueillir des deux si comme anne pour
les accompagner vers le sevrage coller à
une école donc ça on a dit c'est non
maintenant il ya d'autres propositions
qui sont faites on espère qu'il y en a
d'autres qui seront faites évidemment
notre souhait c'est de continuer à
avancer dans la concertation avec les
services de l'état avec les
collectivités locales avec les riverains
et pas dans la brutalité sur le deuxième
sujet que vous avez évoqué notre pays a
fait face à une crise historique et
notamment une crise économique
notre conviction et je pense que pour
l'instant les faits économiques donnent
raison c'est qu'il a fallu faire pour ça
le quoi qu'il en coûte qui ont été des
dépenses évidemment nécessaires pour
protéger les entreprises et les emplois
dans notre pays si on n'avait pas fait
le quoi qu'il en coûte on aurait
probablement dû dépenser 2 3 fois plus
dans les années à venir parce qu'on
appelle des dépenses passives pour des
personnes qui se seraient retrouvés par
millions au chômage des entreprises qui
auraient fait faillite donc on a eu
raison de faire cette politique et
ensuite si on veut que notre économie
reparte il faut évidemment la relance et
pour ça il ya un plan de relance
européen qui a été décidé qu'ils
financent 40% du plan de relance
français et puis d'un plan de relance
français qui se déploie on a aujourd'hui
de très bons indicateurs on prévoit une
croissance de 6% en 2021 s'est nettement
au dessus de la zone euro on nous
annonçait un million de chômeurs en plus
on est retombé aujourd'hui au taux de
chômage le connaissait notre pays avant
la crise du coc vide donc les signaux
économiques montrent que notre réponse
économique est bien calibrée est
évidemment que notre responsabilité
absolue c'est de continuer à relancer
l'économie de notre pays
indépendamment des échéances qui
arrivent imaginez encore une fois ce que
je disais tout à l'heure à julie marie
lecomte imaginer ce qu on nous dirait si
aujourd'hui on se mettait à arrêter
d'agir ce prétexte qu'ils à une élection
c'est déjà le cas ça devrait déjà être
le cas normalement on est un président
élu pour cinq ans le gouvernement et
nommé doit agir jusqu'au bout mais là en
période de crise sanitaire de crise
économique ça justifie encore plus
d'agir jusqu'au bout et d'être au rendez
vous de nos responsabilités
vos propos sur la situation difficile
dans le nord-est parisien avec donc la
présence de toxicomanes vous avez dit
nous avons fait notre part est ce que
vous entendez ou est ce que vous dites
que la mairie de paris n'a pas fait sa
part ça n'est pas ce que je dis ce que
je dis c'est que on a fait notre part je
le disais tout à l'heure avec
la mobilisation de forces de l'ordre de
manière pérenne supplémentaires pour
lutter contre les trafics en dégageant
des moyens financiers pour des places de
repos pour des professionnels de santé
on est prêt à apporter des moyens
financiers supplémentaires et ça sera
notamment il ya un financement via
l'assurance maladie pour le dispositif
issu de la loi touraine en 2016 que veut
mobiliser la mairie de paris mais que
pour ça il faut identifier des lieux
évidemment ça se sent et que donc quand
j'avais été interrogé sur ce sujet là
vous en souvenez il ya quelques mois
j'avais dit qu'on attendait les
propositions de la mairie de paris les
propositions sont arrivées parmi ces
propositions il ya le fait d'installer
une de ses salles à proximité immédiate
d'une école ça nous semble juste
totalement impossible donc c'est ce
qu'on a répondu à la maire de paris et
nous on est prêt à continuer à avancer
évidemment parce que c'est un enjeu
majeur pour les riverains et pour les
toxicomanes
bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
je vous remercie et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine